- When you drink tea, like
what do you think about?
- Honestly, I think like,
tea is therapeutical, man.
("Peaceful Bamboo and
Swinging Bird Remix")
- I'm just a hot blooded
American, you know.
I prefer coffee I think.
- I love tea.
I drink it every day.
- Drink some (bleep) juice.
("Peaceful Bamboo and
Swinging Bird Remix")
This looks like a pool in Brooklyn.
- Hey, cheers.
- Cheers.
- Whee.
- This is exciting.
- It's slightly bitter,
very earthy undertones.
- I like it.
- It kinda reminds me
when you had tea parties
when you were younger,
and I would just eat the sugar cubes.
- Is this like antioxidants?
It's probably good for
your digestive system.
- Yo, Japanese people know a lot of stuff.
("Peaceful Bamboo and
Swinging Bird Remix")
- Whew, I am liking what I see here.
- Oh, so it has a lot of milk?
Here comes the bubble guts.
- You're lactose intolerant?
- I think so, dawg.
- Really?
- Hmm mm, but it's all good.
- Mmm, that is so good.
- I don't know if I
like this biscuit thing?
- You don't like it?
- It's really sweet, and you'll love it.
- The texture of this actually kind of
reminds me of biscotti.
- Is it worth the consequence?
Yeah.
("Peaceful Bamboo and
Swinging Bird Remix")
- Brits love their tea.
And we did too, and then we
dumped it all in a harbor.
Now we like coffee.
- Cheerio.
- Cheerio, tip top.
- It's so good.
- I didn't realize this
was an English muffin
until you, I thought this was
like a natural like bagel.
- A natural bagel?
The ones that grow like on the bagel tree?
(laughs)
- The one thing about Brits
is they have weird names
like clotted cream.
("Peaceful Bamboo and
Swinging Bird Remix")
Did you just eat a mouthful of balls?
- It's so good.
- It's also like a fun activity.
- I did not expect them
to be this texture.
- Swallow it?
Swallow it.
Debbie, swallow it.
(laughs)
- A sugar free gummy bear that's a ball.
- I think that this
would be great on a date.
- I disagree.
- You guys, try something new.
Drink some tea.
Take it easy on the milk.
Yo, you ever had black tea before?
- You ever had black tea?
- You ever had that black tea?
- That black tea though.
(laughs)